poor people need it rich people keep it
and only a few can resist it it can make
us happy but not always intrinsically it
has zero value but then it's maybe the
only thing in the world we all agree to
trust to see how money came about it
helps to understand its history
[Music]
first there was barter a system in which
people simply exchanged what they wanted
with what they had this simple trait of
goods led to an immense increase in
specialization economic growth and
wealth to find each other and exchange
what they had for what they needed
people formed markets to ensure their
produce could be trusted they later
invented Brands but there was a problem
barter is based on a double coincidence
of wants which means that people who
wanted each other's stuff also had to
find each other in a world without forms
of telecommunications this wasn't easy
and as a result they often had to go an
extra mile to find their luck around 3
500 years ago someone came up with the
idea to weigh products in the form of
rare metals and gold and silver became a
medium of Exchange
this was possible because there was a
shared belief that gold was as beautiful
as it was scarce gold allowed us to
replace barter and make and sell things
and then save the income of our earning
the ability to store value was born this
meant we were able to take the earnings
of our work into the future which led to
an immense increase in Innovation and
specialization trade exploded and as a
result a lot of wealth was created
around a thousand years ago some smart
businessmen realized that trust itself
was as good as gold in exchange for
goods they simply promised the seller to
give them the gold later and handed them
a letter of credit instead paper notes
had the advantage that they were lighter
than gold and easier to count store and
protect rulers and politicians then soon
realized that they can issue these notes
themselves and started prohibiting
others to do so to win the trust of
their people they promised to pay back
every note with an equivalent amount of
gold
around 100 years ago rulers began
craving for more money than they had and
so they stopped backing it with gold and
just began printing as many notes as
they needed the so-called Fiat money was
born
the newly printed money was often given
to business owners in the form of cheap
loans this allowed them to invest higher
and increase economic activity employees
who earned and saved that money realized
that while prices of everyday Goods went
up over time the buying power of their
savings went down as a result they often
spend their savings fast further
increasing economic activity
but soon some began to understand that
while their incomes remained relatively
flat housing and company stocks kept
rising and Rising inflation of asset
prices happened because while there was
more and more money there was still just
the same limited amount of land to buy
some started to argue that whenever
governments print new money they
effectively reduced the savings of the
poor and increase the prices of homes
usually owned by the rich this is one
reason people began searching for a new
form of money
cryptocurrencies like Bitcoin are the
latest form of money they work just like
the others because people can place
trust in them unlike Fiat money Bitcoins
are created by a decentralized network
of mathematical code that means that
they can be transferred directly from
person to person without the involvement
of middlemen and no one can increase the
fixed amount of 21 million Bitcoins
there are which is the main reason
people trust and save them
what do you think will history end here
in Bitcoin become and remain the last
form of money and if Bitcoins disappear
again which form of money can we all
agree to trust going forward before you
make your argument you may want to know
that so-called honest or good money
usually has five characteristics
scarcity durability portability
divisibility and verifiability
[Music]
if you found this helpful check out our
other videos and subscribe if you want
to support our work join us on
patreon.com sprouts for more information
and additional content visit
sproutschools.com